times in our dealings with power series
we might want to take the derivative or
we might want to integrate them and in
general we can do this term by term what
do i mean by that well that means that
the derivative of f
f prime of x is just going to be the
derivative of each of these terms so
that's going to be the sum from n equals
1 to infinity and let's see the
derivative of x to the n is n times x to
the n minus 1. so i could write this as
n times x to the n minus 1 all of that
over n and these ends will cancel out so
this is just going to be
this is just going to be x
to the n minus 1. so this is taking the
derivative with respect to x similarly
we could integrate
we could integrate and we could evaluate
we could evaluate the integral of f of x
dx and this is going to be equal to some
constant plus if we integrate this term
by term
and so this is going to be equal to the
sum from n equals 1 to infinity and
let's see we increment the exponent so x
to the n plus 1 and then we divide by
that so times n plus 1 times this n
right over here so this is a common
technique that you will see when dealing
with power series we're going to go a
little bit more into the details because
you can only do this for x values within
the interval of convergence for the
power series and as we will see the
interval of convergence for these
different series is slightly different
the intervals are very similar but what
happens at the end point is different
so i encourage you pause this video and
see if you can figure out the interval
of convergence for each of these series
this is the integral of our original
series and this is the derivative of our
original series
so let's start with our original series
let's figure out the interval of
convergence and we could do that using
the ratio test so the ratio test we
would want to do the limit
the limit as n approaches infinity of a
sub n plus 1 so that's going to be x to
the n plus 1
over n plus 1 divided by a sub n so
that's x to the n
over n so we want to take the absolute
value of that that's going to be the
limit
as n
approaches infinity let's see this is if
you divide this and this by x to the n
that's going to be a 1
and this is just going to be an x and
then this n is going to end up up top so
this is going to be
x n
over n plus 1.
and this is equal to the limit
as n approaches infinity of let's see if
we divide the numerator and the
denominators here by 1 over
if we divide both of the numerator and
denominator by n we're going to get x
over 1 plus 1 over n
and what is this going to be
well this term is going to go to 0 so
this is just going to be equal to the
absolute value of x
and the ratio test tells us that this
series is convergent if this right over
here is less than 1 it's divergent if
this is greater than 1 and it's
inconclusive if this equals 1. so we
know let's write that down we know we
are convergent
convergent
for
the absolute value of x less than one
when this thing evaluates when it is
less than one we know that we are
divergent
divergent when this thing is greater
than one when the absolute value of x is
greater than one but what about when the
absolute value of x is equal to one
that's where the ratio test breaks down
we have to test that separately
so let's look at the scenario
where
x is equal to one when x equals to one
this series is
the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of 1 to the
n over n well that's just going to be 1
over n this is the harmonic series or
the p series where our p is one and
we've seen in multiple videos that this
diverges
so when x equals one we diverge but what
about when x equals negative one
when x equals negative one this thing
becomes the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of negative
1 to the n over n and this is all often
known as the alternating harmonic series
and this one by the alternating series
test this one actually converges and
we've seen that in multiple videos
so it turns out the interval of
convergence for our original thing right
over here our interval of convergence
interval
of
convergence
convergence here is
we can x can be
so it could be x can be
greater than or equal to negative 1 or i
could say negative 1 is less than or
equal to x because if x
is negative 1 we still converge but then
x has to be less than 1 because right at
1 we diverge so we can't say less than
or equal to so this is the interval of
convergence for our original function
what about the integral of convergence
for this one right over here when we
take the derivative
well when we take the derivative
this is
this is the same thing as
x to the
plus x to the first
plus x to the second and we go on and on
and on now you might recognize this this
is a geometric series with common ratio
of x
geometric
series
series where our common ratio often
denoted by r is equal to x and we know
that a geometric series converges only
in the situation where
the
where our common ratio or the absolute
value of our common ratio
so converges
converges
only in the situation where the absolute
value of our common ratio is less than
one so in this situation when we took
the derivative for f prime of x our
interval of convergence is almost the
same so here our interval
interval of
convergence
is going to be
x has to be between negative 1
and one but it can't be equal to
negative one if at negative one we would
actually diverge and at one we would
diverge so notice these are almost the
same if we view these as
as series centered at zero the radius of
converges the radius of convergence is
the same we can go one above one below
one above one below and that's in
general true as we take derivatives
integrals but the endpoints of our
interval of convergence can be different
and to continue to see this i encourage
you to use the ratio test to figure out
one
what is the inter well use a ratio test
plus using the boundary conditions
figure out what the interval of
convergence is for this for the
antiderivative for the integral here and
what you will see is
the radius of convergence is the same we
can go one above zero and one below zero
we have to be in that interval but as
you will see this one converges for x
equals negative one or x equals one i'll
just cut to the chase here
so interval
of can let me write that in yellow
the interval of convergence for this top
one
converges
negative 1 is less than x is less than
or equal to 1. so notice they all have
the same radius of convergence but the
interval of convergence it differs at
the endpoint and if you want to prove
this one for yourself i encourage you to
use a very similar technique that we
used for our original function use the
ratio test you're going to come to this
conclusion right over here and then test
the case is when x is equal to 1 and x
is equal to negative 1. and you will see
when x is equal to negative 1 you have
an alternating p series so that's going
to converge and then when x equals 1
you're going to have a p series where
the denominator has a degree larger than
one or something similar to a p series
and you can establish that it will also
converge in that scenario as well